Are you tired of watching your crops
struggle in dry
conditions? Introducing lowcost
irrigation techniques that can transform
your small farm. First up, let's talk
about drip irrigation. It's easy to set
up and delivers water directly to the
roots. Conserving both water and
nutrients. Then there's the power of
rainwater harvesting. Collecting
rainwater can save you money and keep
your fields thriving during dry spells.
How about using simple soaker hoses?
They're an affordable way to ensure your
plants get the moisture they need
without breaking the bank. And don't
forget about mulching. It helps retain
soil moisture and keeps those weeds at
bay.
Win-win. These techniques not only save
you money, but also boost your crop
yield
significantly. Imagine the difference it
could make. So why wait? Start
implementing these techniques today and
watch your farm flourish.